[Music]
imagine
how different your life would be if you
had a condition that made your vision
poor
being outdoors risky and your appearance
different from everyone else doesn't
sound easy
but for the duration of this episode
you're going to experience what it would
be like
if you were albino would you have
red eyes how would your genes be
different
and why could the sun kill you
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if everyone was albino
according to the national organization
for albinism and hypopigmentation
albinism occurs in all racial and
ethnic groups in the united states
approximately 1 in 18 to 20
000 people have some type of albinism
in other parts of the world the
occurrence can be as high as
one in three thousand it
happens everywhere but albinism
is most common in sub-saharan africa
it can be difficult for albinos to make
a living in these regions
their skin is so sensitive to sunlight
that
they can't do agricultural work and
growing food
is the main income producing activity in
many rural areas
but lack of income isn't the only threat
to albinos
[Music]
in tanzania at least 75
people with albinism have been killed
since 2000.
what spurred these tragic murders
in some parts of the world it's believed
that albino body parts possess
magical powers and are sold on the black
market for as much as 75
000 even if you don't live in
sub-saharan africa
you'd still face discrimination and
stigma
it's a giant q-tip hank but
what really is albinism and why does it
have such a huge effect on your body
it all starts with melanin melanin
creates the color of your skin hair and
eyes
you have several genes that produce and
distribute this
complex polymer but sometimes
one of those genes doesn't work
correctly causing
a lack of melanin this results
in the snow white appearance that we
imagine when we think about
albinism but there are actually
different types of
albinism oculocutaneous albinism
affects your eyes hair and skin
it's more common than ocular albinism
which
involves only your eyes we're going to
stick with oculocutaneous albinism in
this episode which
is the type that affects your whole body
so
what would happen if everyone became
albino
well we're going to skip over the
immediate chaos and
jump to a future where we've got things
a little more figured out
and even though we're all albino
you wouldn't look like everyone else
the amount of melanin and pigmentation
in your skin and hair
would still differ from person to person
your
eyes would most likely be blue but they
could also be hazel or
brown and no they wouldn't be red
sometimes an albino's eyes can look red
that's because the blood vessels at the
back of the
eye become visible when the lighting is
just right
but the whole red eyes thing is a myth
living with albinism you definitely make
different fashion choices you'd want
more coverage
especially in the summer you'd enjoy
wearing nice
linen pants or long lightweight dresses
sun hats with large brims and big
sunglasses would be
all the rage why the lack of melanin in
your skin
would make you prone to skin cancer
in africa 90 of albinos
die from skin cancer before they reach
age
but with the right treatment and
precautions
like protective clothing and sunscreen
you could avoid
dangerous sun exposure slathering your
body and sunscreen would be
part of your morning routine you'd also
stay indoors when the sunlight is most
intense
only enjoying outside activities in the
morning
and evenings or you might decide to move
somewhere with less sunlight
like regican a village in the south of
norway
nestled between the mountains it only
receives direct sunlight for
half the year but sunnier cities
would adapt to everyone's needs huge
sun shades would be constructed outside
restaurants and public areas
and super sensitive skin wouldn't be the
only thing you'd have to contend with
you'd also have problems with your
vision
most albinos are legally blind
this means that your natural vision
would not allow you to perform
some everyday tasks without assistance
so we'd all be using handheld magnifiers
e-readers and glasses and
braille could become the world's most
common written language
but with a legally blind population
our infrastructure would need some major
changes
you'd mostly rely on a robust public
transportation system
outfitted with visual cues if
you have enough money you'd own a
self-driving
electric car and if you were one of the
few people who were
able to drive you'd enter the
specialized and
highly sought after field of driving
if everyone woke up one day with
albinism
then hopefully we'd understand that
there's nothing
mythical or superstitious about it and
we'd all have more compassion and
if we redesign our cities with
everyone's unique needs in mind
it could help all of us how would your
work and
neighborhood change if everyone was
completely blind
well that's a story for another
what if